president Trump offered his unfiltered
instant response to the attacks on
Twitter in one post he wrote we must
stop being politically correct and get
down to the business of security for our
people in another tweet he took a swipe
at the mayor of London Margaret Vernon
is at the White House with the fallout
from the president's reactions Margaret
good morning good morning well this
could be a consequential week for
president Trump who appears unlikely to
block fired FBI director Comey from
testifying before a Senate committee
this week about that ongoing Russia
probe the White House wants to stay
focused on security and other signature
issues this bloodshed must end this
bloodshed will end at a Sunday night
reception at the Ford theater President
Trump out to stop terrorism I will do
what is necessary to prevent this threat
from spreading to our shores and work
every single day to protect the safety
and security of our country
before speaking with British prime
minister Theresa May mr. Trump's first
reactions came on Twitter where he
pointed to the terror attack as a reason
to support his Court suspended travel
ban on six muslim-majority countries I'm
appalled and furious that these cowardly
terrorists would deliberately target
innocent Londoners the president also
took aim at London Mayor Sadiq Khan for
these comments Londoners will see an
increased police presence today and over
the course of the next few days no
reason to be alarmed
mr. Trump mocked the attempt to reassure
Londoners not to be alarmed by the
unusual sight of armed officers the
mayor spokesman called it quote an
ill-informed tweet that deliberately
takes his remarks out of context the tip
is yet another awkward moment for US
relations with European allies who are
still reeling from the president's
withdrawal from the Paris climate change
agreement a deal negotiated by former
Secretary of State John Kerry he's going
to go out and find a better deal that's
like I mean that's like OJ Simpson
saying it's going to go out and find the
real killer everybody knows he isn't
going to do that because he doesn't
believe in it mr. Trump previously
called climate change of hopes but on
Sunday UN Ambassador nikki Haley
suggested his view
may have changed he believes the climate
is changing and he believes pollutants
are part of that equation as for the
president's own agenda later today he'll
unveil a proposal to have state cities
and corporations fund the rebuilding of
roads bridges and other infrastructure
and Gail the president will also endorse
the idea of spinning off air traffic
control to a private corporation to
guide flights landing in the US okay
Margaret thank you